Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
The better fluid simulation techniques out
there typically run on our graphical cards,
which, if we formulate the problem in a way
that the many compute units within can do
in parallel, if they row in unison, if you
will, we'll be greeted by an incredible bump
in the speed of the simulation.
This leads to amazingly detailed simulations,
many of which you'll see in this footage.
It's going to be really good!
However, sometimes we have a simulation domain
that is so large, it simply cannot be loaded
into the memory of our graphical card.
What about those problems?
Well, the solution could be subdividing the
problem into independent subdomains and solving
them separately on multiple devices.
Slice the problem up into smaller, more manageable
pieces.
Divide and conquer.
But wait, we would just be pretending that
these subdomains are independent, because
in reality, they are clearly not, because
there is a large amount of fluid flowing between
them, and it takes quite a bit of algebraic
wizardry to make sure that the information
exchange between these devices happens correctly,
and on time.
But if we do it correctly, we can see our
reward on the screen.
Let's marvel at it together!
Oh, hohoho, yeah!
I cannot get tired of this.
Typically, the simulation in the individual
subdomains are computed on one or more separate
graphical cards, and the administration on
the intersecting interface takes place on
the processor.
The challenge of such a solution is that one
has to be able to show that the solution of
this problem formulation is equivalent to
solving the huge original problem.
And, it also has to be significantly more
efficient to be useful for projects in the
industry.
The paper is one of the finest pieces of craftsmanship
I've seen lately, the link is available in
the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!